[Music]
the last week of September was banned
books week when all over the country
libraries and bookstores featured books
that were supposedly being menaced by
censors except that the leftist
organizers of banned books week omitted
all mention of the real censorship
threat today which is coming not from
conservatives but from the left the
banned books week website says banned
books week is an annual event
celebrating the freedom to read banned
books week was launched in 1982 in
response to a sudden surge in the number
of challenges to books in schools
bookstores and libraries typically held
during the last week of September it
highlights the value of free and open
access to information banned books week
brings together the entire book
community librarians booksellers
publishers journalists teachers and
readers of all types in shared support
of the freedom to seek and to express
ideas even though some consider
unorthodox or unpopular yet its list of
the top 10 challenged books of 2017
consists of nothing genuinely unorthodox
or unpopular at all at least among the
leftist elites one book was supposedly
banned for profanity in situations that
were deemed sexually explicit another
was challenged and banned because it
includes a transgender child still
another was challenged and labeled
because it features a same-sex
relationship one book is even included
because it was thought to lead to
terrorism and promote Islam as if those
things would make the book unacceptable
to people who run schools bookstores and
libraries today the left has a
near-total stranglehold on the
educational system the entertainment
industry the means of communication and
the culture in general
yet leftists still like to pose as
fearless Outsiders confronting the
establishment they are the establishment
if banned books week really wanted to
feature books that are not establishment
that are considered unorthodox and
unpopular in a genuine
way it should highlight books by people
who are hated by the leftist
intelligentsia that dominates everything
books by say Donald Trump Alex Jones
Gavin McGinnis Dennis Prager and me I've
recently been banned from patreon and
GoFundMe and MasterCard and discover
card won't process donations to my jihad
watch 501c3 organization
I wrote my new book the history of jihad
from Mohammed to Isis as a challenge to
the elites narrative about jihad in
Islam the elites however don't Brooke
challenges to their narrative it's clear
that I'm in their crosshairs and Muslim
Brotherhood linked congressman keith
Ellison has demanded that Amazon stopped
stocking books by people who are
blacklisted by the Southern Poverty Law
Center no one in the leftist
establishment stops to ponder the
question of whether or not the SPLC is
really a reliable source as to what
constitutes a hate group and what
doesn't if you're on their list the left
wants you silenced and is moving quickly
to silence you free people should thus
seek out the work of those who genuinely
differ from the leftist agenda to do so
would be in keeping with the true spirit
of banned books week which is to
encourage free thought I'll be it it
would not be in keeping with the intent
of those who run that enterprise now the
establishment Aryans who run banned
books week won't tell you this but I
will the authoritarian Left is working
energetically now to ban all dissenting
voices in the run-up to the 2018
elections the elites are moving as fast
as they can now to muzzle all dissenters
nor will they stop after those elections
Alex Jones has been banned nearly
everywhere and for what people may think
his views are eccentric or offensive or
even crazy I don't know but ultimately
it's irrelevant he should be able to
speak like everyone else and if a crowd
gathers and believes what he is saying
it is up to his opponents to refute his
claims
convincingly that's how things are done
in a free society which is not quite
what we have anymore
what crime exactly has Alex Jones
committed what laws is he broken when a
man can be denied services because of
his political opinions everyone of all
political persuasions is threatened
and so this is the perfect time for Free
People to strike a blow for freedom and
to read a real unorthodox or unpopular
book by an author who has been
challenged and censored the dreary
leftist conformists of banned books week
probably won't like you to read any
genuinely banned authors and that's all
the more reason why you should
I'm Robert Spencer the Shulman fellow
for the David Horowitz Freedom Center
and director of jihad watch this video
has been brought to you by the Center
for security policy
[Music]